é pá bom
entrei com isso aqui não foi à toa o que
eu trouxe aqui será que seja podem me
responder
lixo então isso aqui é o copinho que
cada um usou ele no coffee break ganha
um nome
isso aqui é uma garrafa de água
isso aqui é uma lata de alumínio e aqui
a gente tem um panfleto e um saquinho de
produto porque no momento que a gente
tirou de dentro de si invólucro ele
essas coisas ganhar um nome porque a
partir do momento que a gente bota aqui
dentro
isso ganha um nome chamado lixo
se a gente pensar o nome lixo a palavra
lixo quer dizer alguma coisa que não tem
valor
naquele momento pra você não foi
colocado em outro lugar e algumas
pessoas usam a palavra resíduo também
serão os restos da atividade humana mas
porque a partir do momento que a gente
coloca num saco isso para deixe de
existir pra gente
essas coisas continuam ali elas têm sua
vida
essa essa fase que passou pela gente foi
uma fase da vida delas né a questão do
lixo começou a verdade não começou mas é
a questão do lixo é antiga neper o ser
humano do resíduo das nossas coisas as
coisas que a gente não quer mais
então nas cidades européias antigamente
era um problema que as pessoas jogaram
as coisas que não queriam mais para fora
das janelas
então até as pessoas começarem a colocar
em algum envólucro em algum sexto algum
lugar destinado para isso eleva o tempo
e aí você tem a questão de paz ternos
pastel
a questão com as suas descobertas trouxe
a noção de higiene que acabou
sensibilizando os cidadãos
há realmente recolher colocar no local e
o que a gente faz coloca num saco de
china para um poder público que leva
para fora nosso vista e aí
aqui não existe mais a gente acha que
não é nosso problema mas que aquilo ali
não está mas nosso mundo e essa questão
principalmente com o lixo passa a ser
domesticado ele é verdade isolado se
torna invisível a gente não sente cheiro
não vê então pra gente está resolvido
né essa questão vem comandava muito
principalmente por eu ser designer minha
formação eu sou designer e nós somos
treinados nós recebemos né conhecimento
técnico para transformar os materiais em
cultura material a dar sentido às coisas
para as pessoas usarem e às vezes me
incomodava como isso era rápido como se
transformava em suas mãos
ficava invisível muito rápido
se você pensar numa troca de presente
uma noite de natal
o que sobra no dia seguinte dessa prova
de presente o que vocês vêm a quantidade
de pacotes embalagens papéis de presente
que só serviram para aquele momento
foi tudo muito rápido então isso sempre
me incomodou eu me sentia diretamente
responsável por essas questões
é então que eu fui fazer foi no final
das contas para lá no sul do rio grande
do sul no extremo sul do país e fui
entrar para a antropologia à fiz um
mestrado em antropologia então eu queria
observar como o próprio ser humano
resolvi essas questões será que tem
alguém que pensava diferente do que o
que eu penso com relação receita será
que tem gente que encara diferente essas
coisas e na na região tem um foi
colocado foi implantado um grande
conglomerado industrial que deu uma
alavancada econômica social esse assunto
era sempre muito discutido
eu resolvi pesquisar esses resíduos que
não existe rede resíduo de alto impacto
ele é um em grande volume então eu fui
pela antropologia deixar os objetos
essas coisas que essa indústria achava
que não servia mais para ela ligar e eu
fui atrás dela
deixei ela me ligarem para ver o que
acontecia eu fui parar na periferia do
município vizinho
é um local que eles recebem uma parte
desses resíduos e ali eles processo de
diversas formas através de um negócio
familiar através de práticas que eles
misturam práticas urbanas e práticas
rurais
eu fiquei oito meses em média entre
xiitas em vindo e vendas convivendo com
eles e observando para além do discurso
além do que eles falavam da boca pra
fora o que eles realmente faziam com
aquelas coisas e observei que as coisas
para eles têm um outro valor um valor
completamente diferente do nosso
as coisas que eram descartadas por
outros e chegaram ali ganhavam valor
real valor social enorme
as coisas eram distribuídas as coisas
eram compartilhadas coisas que nós
jogamos o que jogamos fora e quem
partilhava essas coisas acaba vendo o
status na comunidade porque ela tinha
essa pessoa tinha essa bondade dessa
partilha né
e cada um fazia várias coisas desse
resíduo eu vi móveis saindo eu vi
questões para casa é eles usavam muito
nessa periferia específica a gente tinha
essa mistura de rural e urbano então
nessa família eles um quintal inês
quintal
os resíduos é dos próprios resíduos
industriais eram aproveitados ali eram
utilizados e nisso eu comecei a observar
como é que eles próprios lidavam com
seus resíduos domésticos bom se eles
elaboram os industriais vão ver que eles
fazem com os outros
e qual não foi minha surpresa que eles
também elaboram ali eles não vêem aquilo
como uma sobra uma coisa que tem que se
tornar invisível ele simplesmente
encaram que existe em caminhão em
caminho da forma que eles acham melhor
eles acham seus próprios caminhos são as
práticas rurais ali aproveitar um
resíduo orgânico na própria terra para
com os animais etc né
os resíduos sólidos
jesus nos pets e eram aproveitadas ali e
parte também era encaminhada era
separada em caminhada aqui uma imagem
que eu tirei lá
por incrível que pareça eu não ele foi
lá estava lá e assim eu acho que foi um
recado mostrando que a nossa cultura
material as nossas coisas estão lá elas
estão lá presente mesmo que a gente
ignora elas estão lá elas fazem parte de
nós
tá então aqui mostrando bem que eles no
cantinho tem uma separação né então ele
mesmo já encaminhou no final eu observei
que as coisas que chocavam que pra minha
cultura era resíduo que estava fora de
lugar para ele estava no lugar
apropriado eles estavam dando
encaminhamento
então o problema que eu chego à
conclusão é que não é a questão de a
gente achar que é um mau comportamento a
gente botou para fora da cidade é uma
questão de ponto de vista em relação às
nossas coisas
as coisas que passam por nossas mãos a
gente viabilizou elas elas existem
justamente porque passou por nossas mãos
e não adianta a gente também condenar o
consumo
o consumo na verdade faz parte do ciclo
está no mundo do ser humano faz parte
das nossas relações sociais
não tem como a gente viver nesse mundo
sem consumir
então não é essa questão a questão é a
gente assumir a responsabilidade sobre
as nossas coisas sobre o caminho que
elas vão tomar
independente da gente querer ou não elas
vão seguir o seu caminho e o ideal é que
a gente encaminha de uma forma correta
então isso que o tiro de conclusão dessa
história toda assim como a gente cuida
dos nossos bichinhos ou né a gente tem
um ponto de vista mais cuidadoso com os
nossos bichinhos nossas plantas e 800
deveria ter com as nossas coisas saber o
que fazer com elas adquirir pensando a
casca do ovo que você comeu ontem é sua
responsabilidade
a casca da banana também a sua
responsabilidade assim como o saco
plástico do pão que acabou também a sua
responsabilidade porque misturar por
exemplo um com o outro porque não
encaminhar corretamente né
então por exemplo monitores e com
equipamento eletrônico você pode doar
pra instituições que precisem
é e que vão dar um rumo correto para
aquele acho que o segredo é esse a gente
não negar a existência das nossas coisas
não negar que elas estão ali que elas
passaram pela nossa vida que elas estão
dentro da nossa casa e elas têm que ter
um lugar apropriado um espaço apropriado
na nossa vida pra gente encaminhar elas
corretamente
obrigada